eric gardner was unarmed and by all
accounts minding his own business when
new york police officers accused him of
selling loose cigarettes outside a
convenience store
daniel pantaleo one of the officers on
scene put gardner in a choke hold
prohibited under department use of force
guidelines
and that led to the death of the
46-year-old father of six
a grand jury decision not to charge
pantaleo sparked nationwide protests
garner's dying words i can't breathe
became a national rallying cry against
police brutality
five years later pantaleo was fired from
the new york police department and the
city settled a wrongful death claim with
garner's family for several million
dollars
but seven years on gardner's mother gwen
carr says there is still work to be done
there is no justice for eric eric is
gone but we still need closure
and closure would look like to me
if all those officers who was involved
in my son's death that day stand
accountable
and there was transparency in which we
know all of that was trying to try to be
hidden
a judge granted gwen carr's request to
hold a judicial inquiry into her son's
death
such inquiries are very rare the last
time one was held here in new york was
over a hundred years ago and it's not a
trial there will not be a jury and
nobody will be found guilty or innocent
when it's over
but it's a way for lawyers to question
powerful people that dealt with
gardner's death
and a way to get a public record
of who knew what
when
and why certain decisions were made
in a setback to the garner family the
judge decided new york mayor bill de
blasio does not have to testify
saying he can instead submit a written
statement despite being directly named
in the inquiry
critics say that reasoning undermines
the very point of what the inquiry is
meant to address transparency
how do we hold our public leaders
accountable if they're allowed to just
submit statements right when you're
named on a case and you're not being
called to be
active participating vocal
and undersworn or oath it's a pass the
city fought against holding the inquiry
arguing it was unnecessary a
spokesperson for the city's lawyers
declined to request for an interview
gabriel lozando al jazeera new york